[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
SARAH HEWETT: All
right, good afternoon.
We're going to get started
because we have a lot
to talk about for this one
lab before a lot of you guys
get to do it starting next week.
So we are done for now talking
about the essential oil lab,
and you'll get one
more lecture about that
in the X-ray crystallography
stuff coming up next week.
And for now, we're going
to switch gears and talk
about the ester lab.
So before we get
too far into it,
the Ellen Swallow Richards
reports are due next Wednesday
and Thursday, the 16th and 17th.
The TAs will be
holding office hours
and I will post those onto
Stellar this afternoon.
And then starting this
Wednesday and Thursday,
we're going be starting
our next round of labs,
so wherever you are standing,
whichever bay you're
in in the lab, that
will determine which lab
you are going to do next.
So A prime 2, center
of the lab, you'll
be doing essential oils,
middle group, catalase,
and then the people
closest to the wall,
you'll be doing the
ester lab, which
we're talking about today.
If you're doing the catalase
lab, and hopefully your TAs
will remind you of this as well,
but you need to bring a laptop.
You'll be working in pairs,
so if you don't have a laptop,
then we can pair you up
with somebody who has one.
But we need a good number
of laptops to do that.
That's how you'll be
collecting your data,
and we'll talk more about
that starting on Thursday.
But moving on to esters, so
the structure of an ester,
which hopefully you
guys have seen before
in your organic chemistry or
maybe your gen chem classes,
is something like this.
You have an R group
where this first R
group can be a hydrogen,
any alkyl group
or an aromatic group.
Then you have your carbonyl,
another oxygen and then
a different R group.
And this one can only be
an alkyl or an aryl group.
It has to have carbons.
It can't be a hydrogen, or else
you have a carboxylic acid.
So that's the general
structure of esters.
And talking a little bit
about background information
about esters, they are found
naturally in many plants,
and you can synthesize
them in the lab
from carboxylic acids
and alcohols, which
we are going to be doing.
They are highly fragrant,
as you guys will experience
when you do this
lab, and so as such,
they are used extensively in
flavorings, scent and polymer
industries.
And so some esters that you may
have seen before in the world,
this is a triglyceride.
This is how your
body stores fats,
and it makes it from glycerol,
which is an alcohol..
It has three OH groups and
a bunch of fatty acids.
So that's one biological
example of an ester that is very
common in all of our bodies.
And then this is
ethyl cinnamate,
which is an ester that is
found in the essential oil
of cinnamon, and it
is what gives cinnamon
its cinnamony flavor or scent.
The most ubiquitous of
esters is probably polyester.
And so many of you are probably
wearing polyester right now.
It's in your fabrics.
It's what plastic
bottles are made out of.
You have water bottles
or food containers,
all of these things.
If you see this symbol that is
the symbol for this plastic,
which is the most common
one used in our fabrics
and in the food
packaging that we have,
and it is polyethylene
terephthalate,
and this is the structure.
And so you can see that
there is the ethylene group.
There's the terephthalate
group, and then there
is our ester bond in the middle.
And if so if you stack
a lot of these together,
you make a giant polymer, then
you have all type of plastics
that we use for many, many
applications in our daily life.
So a little bit of
background about esters.
And here's a chart of all of
the different types of esters--
or not all of the esters.
There's many, many, many types
of esters that you can make,
but here are some very
common ones, especially
ones that are found
naturally in different food
and natural products.
So you can see there's the
part from the carboxylic acid
and the part from the alcohol.
So if you make any of these
combinations of esters,
then they'll have all
these different scents.
And so in the lab,
you guys are going
to be synthesizing a whole
bunch of different esters,
and one of the ways that
you may be able to identify
it is by what it smells like.
So if you look in
the lab manual,
there's a whole
chart of the esters.
It gives you their name.
It gives you a bunch of
physical information about it,
and it also gives you the scent.
So when you
synthesize your ester,
you will carefully
smell it and see
if it matches up to what it
is supposed to smell like.
AUDIENCE: What are the
boxes that say ethereal?
SARAH HEWETT: Ethereal?
That is kind of--
I've never smelled something
that smells ethereal.
Does anyone have
a good description
of what that may smell like?
I think it doesn't have
like a concrete scent.
That's how I kind
of interpret that.
But you can see there are
some that smell like vanilla,
pineapples, different fruits.
Those are ones that
smell like balsamicy,
like vinegar, coconut, all
kinds of different things.
So we're going to talk
about the reaction
that we're going to be doing.
This is Emil Fischer.
He is half of the team that
is responsible for creating
or inventing this reaction.
I could not find a
picture of the other guy.
He won the Nobel Prize for
chemistry in the early 1900s,
and now it is typically just
called a Fischer esterification
reaction.
So you take your carboxyl
acid, your alcohol, some acid,
and then you can
synthesize an ester.
And so we'll walk
through the mechanism
really quickly so that we
know what is happening.
And you guys have probably--
have you guys seen this in
your organic chemistry classes?
Yes, so this hopefully
isn't too new.
So you start off with
your carboxylic acid.
We're going to add a strong
acid in our case, sulfuric acid,
which is very corrosive.
Be careful when you're
handling it in the lab.
That is our proton source.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is activate this carbonyl.
We get our carbonyl.
Now it has a proton and
a positive charge on it,
and we can draw a
resonance structure
where that positive charge gets
put down on this carbon here.
And when we do that,
we have our alcohol.
We can add our alcohol
in, and these electrons
can come up here and attack
that positively charged carbon.
We can add our alcohol group
to our original molecule.
So now we have this
guy here, and now
the positive charge
is on this oxygen.
And so we can lose
a proton to get rid
of that positive charge.
So then we end up with
a proton over here.
That's an unfortunate proton.
And now we have this structure
here with our extra proton.
We can protonate
this oxygen up here
and form this charged species.
And now we have made
positively charged water,
and we know that water
is a good leaving group.
So we can leave and
make water, and that
is where the water comes
from in our synthesis.
And to kind of balance
this whole thing out,
you're also going to have
these electrons come down
and form a double bond to
help drive that water out.
So now we have a
double bond here.
It has a positive
charge and a proton
still on it, so we can have
this proton leave as a proton.
And we have made an ester.
Tada.
And then we've
regenerated our acids,
so that's why the sulfuric
acid is our catalyst.
So I guess we can leave
this here for now.
So that is the mechanism of
the reaction, and like I said,
you guys have probably
seen that before.
It's pretty straightforward,
and so this is the reaction
that we will be
doing in the lab.
Now we need to talk
about naming esters,
and there are a couple
of conventions that
are used when naming esters.
There's a few ways to do it.
So the first one is the
IUPAC straightforward way
to name esters, and you start
with the part of the molecule
that comes from the alcohol.
So if you notice over
here, the blue stuff
came from the alcohol,
and it ends up
as this group that's
attached to the oxygen,
not on the carbonyl
side of the molecule.
So you're going to start there.
You'll name it as though it's an
alkyl group, so something that
is attached.
So it'll have that -yl
ending, like methyl, ethyl,
that kind of thing.
So this is a propyl group.
It has three carbons.
The second step is to look at
the other half of the molecule,
and you want to name it as
though it isn't just an alkane
and count up all the carbons
including this one attached
to the carbonyl.
So you have one, two,
three carbons over here
as well, so that
would be propane.
And then you want to drop
the e off the end of the name
and add -oate, So proponoate.
So the IUPAC way
to name this thing
is then to combine the names.
So you'll get
propyl, proponoate.
So clear enough?
It gets a little bit tricky
because chemists don't always
use the IUPAC or traditional
names for everything.
There are some common names
that get used and thrown
around when people are talking
about different chemicals.
So does anybody know what
this carboxylic acid is?
Acetate or acetic acid.
So acetic acid is what
we typically call it.
You'll hear it as
an acetate group
if you take off that proton.
If you're going to name
this according to the IUPAC
convention that I just told
you about, there's two carbons,
so that's ethane, and you
would call it ethanoic acid,
but that's not commonly used.
This alcohol is ethanol.
So if you combine these two,
what would we call that ester?
Ethyl ethanoate, or you
can use the common name
and call it ethyl acetate,
which you guys may have heard of
or remember from
the ferrocene lab.
Yes.
So there are a couple
of different ways
to name the esters, and
there's a whole list of esters.
If you guys have
looked in the manual,
there's a whole list of possible
unknowns that you can have
and that you can
make in this lab,
and they come from all
different combinations
of carboxylic
acids and alcohols.
And so in order for you guys
to have some idea of what
you may be making
and the structures
that you will be looking for
when you are characterizing
your esters that you
make by different types
of spectroscopy, we need
to be able to name and draw
the esters.
So if you got this handout
in the back, on one side,
it has a sheet that has
all of the common names
for the structures that you
may find in that list of esters
that we'll be making in the lab.
And then on the back,
there is a blank chart.
Mine's already filled
in, but there's
a blank chart that has a bunch
of different ester names.
So if we want to take a
moment and practice naming
these esters using the
information in the past two
slides you should have on
your PowerPoint handout
and the structures
on the back of here,
you should be able to
draw the structures of all
of these different esters.
So take a moment do that and
talk with your neighbors.
Work it out.
Ask your TAs if
you're back there.
And then I'm going
to have people,
when you are confident
that you know
the structure of
one of these guys,
come down here and
draw it please.
So I'll give you a couple
of minutes to do that.
All right, can I get a
few people to come help
draw some of these on the
board if you have drawn
some of these on your paper?
Go for it.
Going to need a few other
people, or else this
is going to take forever.
Excellent.
Wonderful.
Anyone from the back
want to come down?
Go for it.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH HEWETT: Don't
worry if it's wrong.
If you want to draw more
than one, go for it.
If anyone else wants to come
down here and be really brave
and share their knowledge,
that would be excellent.
All right, we'll see how many
of them these guys can do.
Yeah, if more than one, go for
it because it'll be faster.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah,
sorry about that.
One more.
All right, how are we looking?
Good, except this one, I think,
these are the same molecule.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH HEWETT: So butyl acetate,
it's just no double bond.
Thank you.
Well done.
So there are the structures
of some of the esters
that you may or may not
be making during this lab.
It's good practice.
So these aren't all of
them, so you'll still
have to draw out some of
the possible structures
when you are trying to figure
out what your unknown might be,
but this is a good
start and good practice.
So it looks like you guys are
good at drawing the esters.
Well done.
All right, so now that
we have the idea of what
the reaction looks like on paper
and what our products could
possibly be, we're going to
talk about how we can actually
do this in the lab.
And so I brought
some of the glassware
that you're going to be using.
And I'm going to put
gloves on because I
don't know how well whoever used
this last semester cleaned it.
So the first technique that
you're going to use is reflux,
and so that's to do the
first part of, or pretty much
do the whole
reaction here, where
you're going to combine
your carboxylic acid
and your alcohol.
You're going to heat it up,
and to reflux means to boil
without losing solvents.
So it'll be boiling.
You'll have a stir bar in there.
So you can see you
have your stir plate.
You're going to use a
heating mantle again
to heat your reaction.
It'll be boiling
in there, and then
instead of using
our Vigreux column
like we did in the
distillation, you're
just going to put a
condenser on there.
So you'll have water going
through your condenser.
You'll want your water going
in the bottom and out the top
so that the whole thing
fills up with cold water,
and so that's when
you're boiling.
Your solvent will
be evaporating,
and then it'll
condense and it'll
go back down so that you
don't boil to dryness
and you don't lose all of your
product as you're boiling it.
And then on the top, you're
going to put a drying tube,
and your drying tube
will look like this.
And when you get it, it will
be empty just like this one is,
and then you will fill it.
You'll put a little bit of
cotton in here as a plug,
and then you will take this
stopper off and fill the rest
of it with calcium chloride.
Does anyone know why
we're going to do that?
And it goes right on top here.
So calcium chloride is CaCl2.
It is among other things
used as a road salt.
So there are three
ions in the structure,
and if you remember your
colligative properties,
then it'll lower the
freezing point of water
when it has three ions in it.
It's a very good electrolyte.
It'll also lower the vapor
pressure of a solution
or increase the boiling point.
And the dissolution of calcium
chloride is exothermic.
It's very
thermodynamically favorable
and it's also
entropically favorable,
so it is a very
spontaneous reaction,
and it is a hygroscopic
material, which
means that it absorbs water.
So it's a desiccant.
You may see those like
silica gel packets
in things that you may
buy to keep the water out.
Calcium chloride is another
material that's commonly
used as a desiccant
because it's hygroscopic,
but it has a property even
beyond being hygroscopic.
It is deliquescent, which
means it'll absorb water
until it becomes a solution.
So this is what dry calcium
chloride pellets look like.
So it's just little
white chunks of solid.
And if you leave it out on
the benchtop for long enough,
it'll actually pull in
the water from the air
and turn itself into a calcium
chloride brine solution.
So if you spill some
of this on the bench,
you want to clean it
up really quickly,
or else it will start
to look like that.
And so what we're
going to use it
for in our reaction
is-- what are
the products of our reaction?
We're going to
make an ester and?
Water.
So if we go back to our
mechanism, we lose water here.
And if you notice,
most of these steps
here are reversible steps.
So if you remember Le
Chatelier's principle,
if this is our overall
reaction and one
of our products
over here is water,
and this is a
reversible reaction,
then how can we
force the reaction
to go towards the product side?
AUDIENCE: Take out the water.
SARAH HEWETT: Take
out the water.
You can either
add more reactants
or take out the
products, and so we
are going to be taking out the
water with our drying tube.
And so that will help ensure
that our reaction goes
to completion while
we are refluxing.
So once you've done
all of your reflux
and you have your product,
you've heated it for a while--
it's kind of boring to watch,
but reactions take time--
so then you will
have your product
in your round-bottom flask here.
And we will have our ester,
hopefully, and what else?
Potentially all of these things,
right, and some sulfuric acid.
So we don't know that our
reaction went to completion.
We hope that it
got close, but we
need to purify it from any
impurities or remaining
starting material
that we may have.
So we do that in a
separatory funnel,
and this is a separatory funnel.
And we do a
liquid-liquid extraction,
which means that we're
going to have one liquid,
and then we're going to add
a different liquid to it.
So we have two liquid
phases, and we're
going to partition the different
compounds between those two
liquid phases.
And the only way
this works is that we
have to have two
immiscible liquids that
have different densities.
So what does it mean for
something to be immiscible?
AUDIENCE: They
won't mix together.
SARAH HEWETT: They
don't mix together.
Good.
So when you pour your
two solvents in here,
they need to not mix so that
have two distinct layers
and that you can separate
your product between them.
And it will separate
them based on density.
So when you have your
separatory funnel,
you will pour your
two things into it,
and you should get two layers.
And so your more dense
layer will be on the bottom
and your less dense
layer will be on the top.
So in our case, water
has a density of about 1
and most organic liquids have
a density of less than 1.
So if you take your
product, which is an ester,
and you add water to it,
what will be on the top
and what will be on the bottom?
AUDIENCE: The water
will be on the bottom.
SARAH HEWETT: Yep.
So this will be
our aqueous layer
and this will be our product
or our organic layer.
And it's really
important that you
keep track of what
is where when you're
using the separatory
funnel and that you
know what you've drained out
and what you have kept in there.
And you want to save everything.
Save all of the stuff
that comes out of here.
Save all the things that
are in there until you know
that you have your product.
So there are a couple
of ways that we
can use a separatory
funnel or as a sep funnel,
the abbreviated version.
And the frequently
used solutions
for this type of
extraction, the first type
is an acid-base extraction or
a chemically active extraction,
and that's the first thing
that you're going to be doing.
So in our reaction
mixture, we have
hopefully a lot of product.
We probably still have some
carboxylic acid left over,
and we know that we have
some sulfuric acid in there.
Yes?
Great.
So the way to get all
of that acidic byproduct
away from our product is to
use sodium bicarbonate, which
is a base.
And when we do that--
so if we have our carboxylic
acid, if you add a base to it,
then you can deprotonate it, and
if we have sodium bicarbonate,
it will form a sodium salt. And
that is more polar than this,
so it will be more soluble
in our aqueous layer,
and we will pull it
away from our product.
So that's the idea behind
the base extraction.
And so hopefully, that
first round of extraction
will get rid of our
acidic impurities,
and then we're going to do
another extraction using
a sodium chloride solution.
And that is sometimes
referred to as salting out.
So we will keep our
product in there,
and then we will add
sodium chloride solution.
And the sodium chloride makes
our aqueous layer really polar,
and so it makes our product less
soluble in the aqueous layer,
and it makes any water that's
left over in our product layer
more likely to come
into the aqueous layer.
So when this is polar, than
all of the polar things,
all of the water, get pulled
into the aqueous layer,
and any organic-y things, the
product that we care about,
gets forced out into
the product layer.
There's some
terminology that you
may hear when you are
using a separatory funnel.
So there's extraction,
which is if your product is
in a mixture and
you to add another
solvent to extract your product
out of what's already there.
And then there's washing, which
is we're going to be doing,
which is where you're just going
to pour your product in there
and you are going to
add other solvents
to extract the impurities.
You leave your
product where it is
and you pull out the impurities.
A note on how to
use a sep funnel,
and I'm going to put goggles
on just for safety here.
This is just water,
but the way that you're
going to do this is
you'll have a ring stand.
It'll hold itself up
right here, and then you
will first make sure that
the stopcock is closed.
So if you pour your product
through here and this is open,
then that's going to be a
really sad time in the lab.
So then you'll pour your product
and whatever you are washing it
with into the sep funnel.
You will get two layers
because you'll have
two different liquids in there.
This is just water.
Then you will cap it.
And then you're going
to shake it like so.
Then you will point it away from
any humans and into your hood
and you will open the vent.
When you are shaking
things that have are really
volatile like organic
solvents, they'll
build up pressure
in here, and so you
don't want anything to explode.
You don't want this
top to come flying off.
You don't want the
glassware to break.
So you want to vent this.
You're going to shake it
a little bit, vent it.
When you first start,
you want to vent it
very frequently so that the
pressure doesn't have a chance
to build up.
When you do this, you
want to point it away
because sometimes, liquid
will come flying out.
You'll hear it.
It'll go pssh.
So you want to be very careful
when you are using this.
Safety note.
What happens when you add
sodium bicarbonate to an acid?
You get a gas.
You get carbon dioxide.
Think baking soda
and vinegar volcano.
So when you are first adding
your sodium bicarbonate
to your product, you
want to not do it
right away in the
separatory funnel,
or else you're going to build
up a whole lot of pressure,
and it's going to create
an unsafe situation.
So you will add those
to a beaker first.
Wait for the bubbling
to stop, and then you
can pour it into your
separatory funnel
and you can do the extraction.
And what you're going to do
is you will open the stopcock,
and then you'll be able to
watch the layers go down.
And here's something.
So if you open the
stopcock and you say,
oh my gosh, nothing's coming
out, what's our problem?
The top is on.
So you want to close it first.
Take the top off and then
it will drain smoothly.
And then you'll
just pay attention,
and you can stop it right when
the interface between those two
layers gets right to
the bottom, and that's
how you're going to use this
to separate your solutions.
But yeah, inevitably,
somebody always
forgets to take the top
off, and they're like,
my sep funnel's broken.
It's not.
Just physics.
So I guess we can
still leave these on.
So that's going to
be all in day one.
You will reflux your product.
Then you will use
your sep funnel.
You will start to purify
it, and then on day two,
you're going to--
Oh, wait.
Before, sorry.
So after you have
isolated your product,
we have just added a whole
bunch of water to it, right.
We've shaken it up with sodium
bicarbonate and sodium chloride
solution.
We don't want water
in our product.
That's not the point of this.
We want to just have
our ester, so we
need to remove the water
that gets left over
from our separatory funnel
situation using a drying agent,
and a drying agent is
similar to calcium chloride.
We typically use sodium sulfate
or magnesium sulfate in the lab
because they're
easy to work with
and they suck the water
into their crystal lattice,
and they necessarily dissolve
very well, which is nice.
And so these are
fairly interchangeable.
They're the most commonly
ones used in lab situations.
Magnesium sulfate sometimes can
harm acid-sensitive compounds,
so if you're doing something
very sensitive in the lab,
you may want to stick
with sodium sulfate,
but for our purposes,
it will be fine.
So what you're going to do
is it comes in powder form,
and you will add some
of it to your product
and you will swirl it around.
And you will look at it, and
then you will run to your TA
and say something like this,
like, ah, is it dry yet.
How much do I add?
And your TA will look at
you and say, I don't know.
You should know this.
So this is how you could
tell if it is dry yet.
The first time that you add your
drying agent, it will clump up
and it'll all be
in one big chunk,
especially if you have
a lot of water in there.
Sometimes you can
even see the water.
If you hold up
your flask, you'll
be able to see a little
bubble of water at the bottom.
That's fine.
You'll add your drying agent.
It'll all clump up.
You'll add a little bit more.
It'll have some smaller
clumps, and then you'll
add a tiny scoop more.
And the rest of it that
you add won't clump up.
It'll look kind of
like a snow globe.
It'll swirl around and
be free-flowing crystals,
and that is how you know
when you are done, when
it doesn't clump up anymore.
So you don't need to
go over and weigh it.
I think there's an approximate
weight in your lab manual.
Like usually, it's
maybe around a gram.
But don't bother
weighing this out.
You can just kind of eyeball
it, scooping a little bit
at a time.
Don't go too crazy
with the first scoop,
because the more of this that
you have in your product,
the harder it will be to
isolate your product later.
So let's say, if you think
of it like at the beach,
if you have a bunch of sand and
then you put a bunch of water
in it, your water
kind of disappears.
And in this case, our
product is the liquid,
so in order to get
our product back,
we will gravity-filter this
away from the drying agent.
And so you want to have
minimal amount of drying agent
so that your product
doesn't get stuck in it
and it's easy to filter later.
OK, so that's all day one.
Then you'll have your
semi-purified and dried
product, and then on day
two, we will purify it
from anything that did not get
taken out in your extraction
process using distillation.
And what I didn't mention
is that for this lab,
you'll be checking out a
kit from the stockroom,
or your TAs will check
this out, and you
will get a kit that has
all of the glassware
that you need to do
the entire lab in it.
And there's a nice list on
here of what goes in this kit.
So on the first day, you
will set up your reflux just
like this, and then
the second day, we're
going to set up an atmospheric
distillation, which
is going to be very similar
to the vacuum distillation
that we talked about before.
But this time, instead of having
all the glassware in one piece,
you get to assemble it yourself.
So you'll have your
Vigreux column.
Then you'll have a
distilling head up here,
and then you will put your
thermometer in the top.
And most of our thermometers
have ground glass joints.
And then you will use
the same condenser
that you used for your
reflux on day one,
and that will go
across like this.
And you will clamp all of
this glassware very well,
and then you will add your spout
to the end of it right here.
And that is your
distillation setup.
You'll have keck clips in your
lab, those yellow things that
hold all of your
joints together.
So you want to make
sure that everything
is clamped and secure
before you start distilling,
because if you have
gaps in your glassware
and then you start heating and
your product becomes a gas,
you will lose it all.
So the distillation
will purify your product
from any remaining insoluble
impurities or higher
boiling impurities that we do
not want in our final product.
And when you do
this, you're going
to collect a few
different fractions.
And so the way that you're
going collect your fractions
in this case, we don't need to
use a cow adapter because we're
not going to be attaching
anything to the vacuum line.
You can see that the spot over
here, instead of attaching it,
this is where you
put your vacuum.
It's just open to the air.
And so you can collect your
fractions in test tubes on ice,
and then you will collect
a few different fractions.
So you usually collect the
first few drops and then
a few different fractions.
If the temperature changes,
you will switch your fractions,
and your TAs will tell
you how to do that.
And then you will monitor
your purity by IR.
So if we go back and
think about the IR
that we talked about
last time, and if we
think about our products and
our reactants, what IR bands
are we going to see in our
carboxylic acid reactant?
We have a C-O stretch, an
O-H C double-bond O. And?
You might see the
CC, you may not.
Those ones are
kind of hard to do
because they don't change
dipole very much when
that bond happens.
So sometimes, maybe a C-C bond.
And what else?
What's in this R group?
Yeah, C-H stretches.
What about our alcohol group?
We'll have another OH stretch.
Of we have a C
single-bond O. Yep.
Do we have one of these?
No.
None of those.
We have some of this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
And then again,
maybe the C-C bonds,
sometimes those are in
the [INAUDIBLE] region.
You probably won't.
Don't spend too much
time looking for these.
These are kind of there
but not easy to see.
So now if we look
at our product,
what do we expect to
be in our product,
assuming we don't have
any water because we've
done our distillation and
our extractions very well?
We have a C double-bond O.
A C single-bond O. A C-H.
Do we have an O-H?
So what are we going
to look for in our IR
to tell if we still have
starting material in there
or not?
AUDIENCE: The O-H [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH HEWETT: The
O-H. And so this
will still have a C double-bond
O, so that one might not
be as easy to tell.
But we definitely should
not have an O-H peak.
So if you take your Ir fractions
and you take your fractions,
you take the IR of
them and then you
start to see the O-H, the
characteristic O-H peak
up way by like
3,000 wave numbers,
then you may want to
test a different fraction
because that one either
has some water in it
or it still has some of
your starting material.
And then once you've determined
which of your fractions
is the most pure, then
you will continue on
with that to do the rest of our
characterization techniques.
And the first one
of those is going
to be boiling point
determination.
So we can determine the
boiling point of the ester,
and that is a characteristic
of each ester.
So you have a chart.
That chart at the
beginning of the lab,
it has a list of all
the boiling points.
So we will measure the
boiling point of your ester,
but before we do
that, we're going
to calibrate the thermometer
just like we calibrated
the melting point apparatus.
So at this time, there are
only two calibration points.
So you'll measure the
freezing point of water.
So you'll get a beaker.
You'll fill it up
with ice, some water,
let the temperature
reach equilibrium.
And you want make sure
there's still ice in it
when you measure so
that it's not water
and it's not heating back
up to room temperature.
And then you will
measure the temperature
of the very cold
water after it's
sat for about 10 to 15 minutes.
While you're doing that, you can
also heat up a beaker of water
on a hot plate, measure it
and heat it up to boiling,
and then you will
measure the temperature
of the boiling water.
And there's a correction
factor in the lab manual
that you will use to calculate
the theoretical boiling point
of water at whatever the
atmospheric pressure is
on that day.
So you'll go get the
barometer from the lab
like we brought
down to the river.
You can measure
the pressure in lab
because we know that
boiling point is related
to the pressure in the
atmosphere and the vapor
pressure, so there is a
correction factor for that.
And then you will plot your
theoretical boiling points
and your theoretical freezing
point versus the ones
you actually
measure, and that'll
give you a two-point calibration
curve for your thermometer
that you're going to use to
determine the boiling point
of your ester.
The apparatus that we will use
to determine the boiling point
of the ester is like so.
You will have your hot plate.
Then you'll have a sand
bath, and then you're
going to use a very
small test tube.
And you will put a very
tiny amount of your ester
in, maybe a milliliter.
And then you will
suspend the thermometer.
We're going to use
digital thermometers.
You'll suspend the
thermometer a few centimeters
above the surface
of your liquid,
and when you heat this up,
your liquid will vaporize.
It'll hit the thermometer
tip and it'll condense,
so you'll see drips coming off
of the tip of your thermometer.
And the temperature will start
to go up, and you want to wait.
So the second thing that you'll
need is a lot of patience.
So the temperature
will go up very,
very slowly as the vapor
reaches the boiling point.
So if you've ever boiled water
and you cooked something,
you know that you'll start
to see steam and water
vapor before the liquid
itself is boiling.
Same thing happens here.
You'll start to see the drips,
but then the temperature
may still be going up.
So this is one of
those things that you
don't want to sit there and
watch because you will become
very impatient and
you'll say, oh, good,
the temperature hasn't
changed in 30 seconds.
This must be it.
But then if you come
back in five minutes,
the temperature
has indeed gone up,
and then you have the
incorrect boiling point.
So this is one of those
things you can set up and then
check on it after a while.
And once the temperature
stops increasing,
that will be your boiling point.
The next thing
that you will do is
you will determine the
density of your unknown,
and this is our density
instrument that is in the lab.
So instead of having to
measure the mass and the volume
yourself to get grams
over milliliters, which
is our unit of density,
you can inject your sample
into the side of
this instrument.
So there's the little
lower-lock valve here,
and there's a syringe, so you
will inject your sample in
and it'll fill up this tube.
The instrument stays
at 20 degrees Celsius
so that we know for sure that
it is the density at 20 degrees
Celsius.
And then you will
press Go and it
will measure the
density for you,
and it'll pop out the
density number right there.
So very simple, and
then you can use that
as an identifying
characteristic of your ester,
and you can compare that again
to the chart in the beginning
of the lab manual to use
as information to help
you identify your unknown.
Then we're going to
measure refractive index.
We talked about
refractometry a little bit
in the essential oil lab.
In the essential oil lab, we
used it to-- oh, that's a typo.
In the essential oil lab,
we used the refractometer
to determine the purity of
our samples, but in this lab,
we're going to use it
as an identification
technique for our esters.
So every liquid has a
characteristic refractive
index, so we can measure the
refractive index, compare it
to the literature value,
and that will also help you
identify your unknown ester.
The second to last
technique we're going to use
is NMR spectroscopy.
And how many of
you guys have seen
NMR before in your classes?
A few people.
All right, so in, I
think about two weeks,
Walt Massefski, who is the
Director of the NMR Facility
here in the
chemistry department,
is going to come and do a very,
very thorough lecture on NMR
and how it works and
how to interpret it.
Unfortunately, that lecture will
happen after some of you guys
take these spectra
in the actual lab,
so I will do a quick briefing on
NMR because we have some time.
And then again, stay tuned.
You will get a much, much
better idea of this technique
from Walt in a couple of weeks.
So NMR spectroscopy,
the idea behind it
is that it uses a very
strong magnetic field
to align nuclear spin states.
And you don't have to know
too much about that, at least
for right now.
I'm sure Walt will
talk more about it.
But the hydrogen nucleus has
a spin associated with it,
and if you apply a magnetic
field in a certain direction,
the spin can either align
with the magnetic field, which
is the lower energy
state, or it can
go against the magnetic field,
which is a little bit higher
in energy.
And so this is a
difference in energy here.
So once you have your
protons in your field--
and you can do other nuclei
too, but we're going to focus
on protons for the moment--
there's a radio
frequency pulse that
is applied that causes some
of these spins to flip.
And then you remove the radio
frequency pulse, reapply
the magnetic field,
and then you wait
for the spin states to go
back down to the ground state.
And because there's an
energy difference associated
with getting the
spin to flip, there's
also an energy difference
associated with when it
goes back to its ground state.
So it will emit energy
at a certain frequency
depending on the
environment of the proton.
We can measure the energy
that gets emitted and plotted,
Fourier-transform it, and
then you get an NMR spectrum.
This is the really quick,
five-minute version.
This will make a lot more sense
when Walt talks about it later.
So the important
thing to note here
is that the frequency of the
energy that a proton emits
as it changes spin state is
related to the environment
of the proton.
So we can use this
to get information
about the different
protons in our molecule,
and we can determine
connectivity,
the number of
protons that we have,
and some information about
how they're bonded together
depending on the different
NMR experiments that you do.
And the three major
pieces of information
that we will be using in our
lab are the chemical shift
of the proton--
so that's again related to
the frequency of the energy--
the integration-- this tells
you how many protons there are--
and then sometimes the coupling.
So if there are protons
next to each other,
they will split
each other's signals
and you'll get multiple
lines in your NMR spectrum.
So as a really,
really quick example,
we can look at our favorite
ester here, ethyl acetate,
and we can look at the different
types of protons that it has.
So how many types of protons
are in this molecule?
Three.
So we have these methyl protons
here, the ethyl protons here,
and then these methyl
protons over there.
So these three are all in the
same chemical environment.
These are in the same
chemical environment
and these are in the same
chemical environment.
So we should expect to see
three signals in the NMR
spectrum of ethyl acetate.
So the way that an NMR
spectrum is laid out,
it's on a scale of 0
to 12, give or take.
It can go beyond that,
but for the purposes
of most organic molecules,
all of the peaks
will be found in this region.
And the location
that a peak appears
or a proton peak
appears is again
related to its
chemical environment.
And the things
that are very alkyl
or have a lot of
stages around them
are going to be further upfield.
We call this upfield
with a lower PPM number.
And things that are
closer to oxygens
or electron-withdrawing
groups are
going to be-- they
call it deshielded.
So the electrons are withdrawn
away from those protons.
It doesn't shield= them from
the magnetic field as much.
So they come up more
downfield, and the way that you
can remember that is
downfield or deshielded
both start with D.
And so if we look at these
protons, which of these do
we think is going to be the most
upfield or the furthest away
from all of our oxygens?
This stuff all the
way on the right?
Yeah.
I just want to make sure
that I am doing this right.
So yes, these
methyl protons will
be the furthest to the right,
and you'll get a signal here.
And so this signal, the
chemical shift value
will be somewhere
probably around 1 or 2.
And then the integration tells
you how many protons it's for,
and that shows up down
here at the bottom.
So how many protons
will the signal equal?
Three from our methyl group.
All right, so if we look
at the remaining two
groups, which one do we think
would be kind of the middle?
All the way on the left.
So these protons here are right
next to an oxygen, so they're
going to be more deshielded, and
these have a carbon in between,
so these will be
our next signal.
So then we'll have
another signal here.
How many protons?
From this group, three.
And so that leaves our
methylene group over here.
That will have another signal
that's further downfield,
and this one will
be two protons.
So already, you
can see that there
are different ways
that you can use this
to identify your molecules.
So if you count up the number
of different unique protons
there are, then you can look at
the number of signals you see,
and that is one way to
identify your product.
You can also use
the coupling, which
is what is going to break these
signals into not just one peak,
but it'll be a few.
So coupling happens
when there are protons
that are next to each other.
So this methyl group is next
to two other protons, right.
And so each of these protons,
each of its neighbors,
will split this signal one time.
So if you have your signal
and it gets split once,
then you have two
signals, and then
if it gets split again
in an equal magnitude,
you end up with three signals.
So this splitting kind
of combines and this peak
gets a little bit bigger.
So this is what is
called a triplet.
So if you have two
neighbors, you get a triplet.
So this peak, that methyl
group will actually
look something like this.
It'll have three peaks
to it with the middle one
being the biggest, and that's
the characteristic pattern
of a triplet.
What about our ethyl group
here, or ethylene group,
methylene group?
We have our two protons.
How many neighbors does this
group have, proton neighbors?
So this has three neighbors.
So that signal is going
to get split three times.
So you'll split it once.
Split it again, so that
would be our triplet.
And then if we split it a
third time, we get four lines.
So this proton
signal will actually
look something like that.
How many proton
neighbors does this have?
None, so will this get split?
No.
So this will stay as a
singlet, one single peak,
because it does not have
any proton neighbors.
So anyone have any questions
about where all of this
came from?
So again, that was the
super quick version of NMR
and the type of information
that you can get from it.
So when you are looking
at the structures
of the potential esters
that you think you may have,
you can probably
narrow it down based
on your boiling point in your
refractive index, your density.
And you can narrow
it down to a few,
and then you will draw
out the structures.
And then you can,
based on the structure,
predict how many NMR
signals you expect to see.
And you can figure out what
you expect the splitting to be,
so if you expect them
to all be single peaks
or if you expect to see
different types of multiplets.
And then when you get
your NMR spectrum,
you can compare the
number of peaks,
the integration of the peaks.
So if you know that you
have a methyl group,
you should be looking for some
signals that integrate to 3.
And that is how you can use
this as a technique to identify
the structure of your unknown.
And again, Walt will do a
much better job explaining
all of this in a bit.
But just so you've
seen it, before you
get a chance to take
your spectrum in lab,
that is a quick introduction.
So once you have all
of this information,
you have your boiling point,
your refractive index,
your density, your NMR
spectrum, your IR spectrum,
you're going to attempt
to identify your unknown,
and this should all happen
at the end of day three.
You'll have all of
this information,
and then you'll be overwhelmed.
You'll sit down,
put it all together
and try to figure out which of
those unknowns in that table
is the one that you made.
You'll fill out an
identification form
that your TAs will
give you, and then
you will bring it to your
TA at the beginning of day
four on the lab and you
will say, this is my ester.
And they will tell you if
you are right or wrong,
and you'll find out that day
if you were correct or not.
And then you will do
one more technique
for your final confirmation.
So if you already know,
then your mass spectrum
should be super
confirmation for you.
And if you were a
little bit off, then
hopefully your
mass spectrum will
be that last piece
that helps you to get
your final identification.
Mass spectrometry, you have
already seen a little bit.
We did the ICPMS
in our last lab.
But there are different,
many different types
of mass spectrometry, and
a bunch of different ways
that you can use that technique.
So ICP uses plasma to
break the compounds apart
into their atoms and ionizes
the compounds that way,
if you remember, hopefully.
What we're going to
be doing this lab
is electronic impact
mass spectrometry,
which instead of
using plasma just
shoots a high-energy beam of
electrons at your molecule.
And it doesn't
have enough energy
to break your molecule apart
into its atoms or anything,
but what's going to
happen is the electrons
will hit the compound and
it will eject an electron
from the compound.
So you'll make what is
called a radical cation.
So it'll have one less electron,
so it'll be a positive charge,
but it only lost one electron,
and since it's organic-y,
it will be a radical.
This also frequently
causes the molecule
to break apart, not always.
Sometimes you will
get the radical cation
of your whole molecule
that will make it
through the mass
detector, and you
will get the mass of
your actual compound.
And other times,
it'll break apart
and you will see a bunch of
pieces of your compounds.
You'll see the mass of different
fragments of your molecule.
So you can use either the
mass of your molecular ion--
so I'll show you what this
looks like in a second.
So this is what the
instrument looks like.
It's right near the ICPMS.
You may or may not have seen
it, and it is slightly older
and looks a lot like the GC
that we talked about before
in the essential oil lab.
And that is because
this is actually
a GC mass spectrometer.
So you inject your compound.
It actually goes through
gas chromatography,
so if you have more
than one compound,
it'll split it into the
different compounds.
And then it'll take
a mass spectrum
of each of those compounds.
We hopefully are only going to
be injecting one compound in,
so you hopefully purified
it sufficiently well
at this point.
But then it'll still
give us a mass spectrum,
and the mass spectrum
looks like this.
So this is our mass-to-charge
ratio or our mass units.
So usually, the furthest
thing, the heaviest thing, that
is where you will
look to see if that
matches with the
expected molecular weight
of your compound.
That's your molecular ion.
So if it gets hit
with the electron,
forms a radical cation and
doesn't break apart anymore,
you will see a peak at
your molecular weight.
And so that is a giveaway
of yes, this is my molecule.
Sometimes, that doesn't happen.
If it's really unstable,
it'll break into pieces,
and you will see--
so each of these
represents a piece of the
molecule that has broken off.
So frequently, you'll
see losses of 15.
So that's when a methyl
group breaks off.
And Dr. Dolan will
be talking a lot more
about mass spectrometry
and what you
will do with this information
and how it all works
in another lecture coming up.
Just to give you, again,
an idea before you
see it and have to
do it in the lab.
This is just a quick
overview and you'll
get a lot more detail
about what all of this
means coming up in a
couple of lectures.
Last but not least, safety for
this lab is very important.
The carboxylic acids
are corrosive and toxic.
They smell terrible.
You can ask Tristan.
He was the one who made
all of the unknowns.
And Brydon did the alcohols,
so he got it slightly better,
but Tristan will tell you
that the carboxylic acids are
very nasty to work with.
Sulfuric acid is also
highly corrosive,
so you don't want to
get that on your hands.
And then you want to
vent the sep funnel,
like we said, away from people.
So if you're working
in a hood with someone,
make sure that
they're not around.
Don't turn around
to talk to somebody
and point it in their face.
The starting materials
smell very bad.
Your product will
smell really nice,
but it'll still smell a lot,
so keep everything in the hood.
This is a very, very smelly lab.
Even if you keep everything in
the hood, if you're walking by,
which everybody is doing
this, you will know.
So we want to limit
the amount of fumes
that get out in the lab.
Keep everything in the hood.
Do not put vials
in the glass waste.
If anything breaks, or if
you like break a pipette
or if you break a
beaker or something that
has contacted your solutions
from the ester lab,
there will be a separate
waste container for those.
Your TAs will come around with
a capped, plastic solid-waste
container to collect
all your vials
so that they are not
in the glass waste
stinking up the entire lab.
And this is key for everybody.
Regardless of what
lab you're doing--
so starting on
Wednesday and Thursday,
we're going to be doing
three different labs
at the same time, and we're
going to try to keep the waste
containers in the bays
with the proper labs
they're associated with.
But pay attention
to the waste labels.
Read the red tag.
If you're holding
something and you're
going to put it in
the waste container,
take the extra second
to make sure it
is the right one for the
lab that you are doing.
There will be three different
sets of waste containers
out there, and we do not want to
mix in between, especially not
acetone with the catalase waste.
If you remember from before--
we may have talked about this.
You will hear about it again.
If you mix the acetone from
any of these organic-y labs
with the hydrogen peroxide
from the catalse waste,
you will generate explosives.
So we are not going to
do that because everybody
is going to read the labels
and dispose of their waste
properly in this lab,
and keep everything
in the hood that should be.
Good?
Excellent.